he's obvious that which so far establish
a mind-blowing idea that complex numbers
are not just numbers but we can think of
them we can represent them geometrically
on the complex plane we can draw this
fancy thing called an Argand diagram and
uh Hagen diagrams are going to become
your very very good friends over the
next couple weeks now here's that we
established first right we started to go
back the arithmetic that we did not
first lesson we looked at addition I
should put my numbers back on actually
no I don't need them zedd one was like
three plus I and said two was 1 plus 5i
right exactly who she was you had said
one is it to the summons M one is it to
is really a translation of either from
said what do you think about adding Z 2
to it you can read over that much or
vice versa because addition is
commutative right we looked at negation
what happens when you slap a minus sign
on the front of a complex number and
what we concluded was you can think of
it my there is reflection like you
reflect across this way or alternatively
what I suggested is a better way to
think about it and the reason will
become clear in the next 10 minutes or
so is that negation really means you
rotate it around the origin by pi
radians okay and that's what gets you
from so the first quadrant around to the
third okay now addition negation which
gave us subtraction what operation is
next multiplication multiplication okay
now to demonstrate multiplication for
you I'm gonna abandon that zi1 and zi2 I
gave you before we can we can't work
with them but this is starting to get a
bit trickier so I'm going to choose some
very very simple examples for you okay
so four is the and I'm just pop this up
in the Iranian corner we're gonna fill
this in like what is multiplication
we'll do that after we've gone through
this process let's just say Zed 1 it's
just the number 1 now every real number
that you know about actually is like one
actually is a complex number
it's just that it's got no imaginary
component ok so what is feeln complex
nobody's just I don't worry about the
eyes where is Zed 1
it's gonna be on the real axis right
because there's no imaginary thought
okay so I'm gonna put my like there's a
place in like there did one now here's
what I want to do like I said I'm
treating very simple example so I can
see what's happening I wouldn't multiply
by a number now what's a nice simple
complex number to choose is it - I'm
just gonna go with I I is the
quintessential comfort Samba right so
multiply one by I just gives me my now
where is I on my complex plane being
that I said to is purely imaginary right
it belongs in line with zero on the real
axis but it belongs up here and there's
Ed to multiplying by I is taking me from
there to there now at the women I don't
know enough you don't have we're done in
series and sequences and you need three
things for a pattern right I've got two
things right now
one two but I don't know what's
geometrically getting me from here to
here it could be translation it could be
reflection across the line you know y
equals x if I wanted to I don't know
enough yet so let's do it again okay
said three when I multiply by I again
I've got I squared now but I knew what I
squared is by definition it's the
negative one where is negative one on my
complex plane negative one is completely
real it's purely real okay so back on
the real axis or video I can't wait
gonna do it one more time to make it
bleeding the obvious if I multiplied by
I one last time
Zed for would be negative one times I
which is anyway now way to ask it again
this time let's just plug this guy he
belongs down here on the negative
imaginary axis okay four times I have
done the same operation okay the first
time away from here to here the second
time way from here to here it's third
time we're first wait three times of
course for wonderful three times I've
done this operation what is the geometry
thing that gets me repeatedly from here
in here to here and you can see even in
the way that I've drawn like moving my
hand right I am clearly rotating around
the origin do you see that okay so what
I thought is I've rotated this far I've
rotated in this case by PI on two
radians right that's 90 degrees when I
multiply by I the second time I rotate
again another high on two radians and
then the last time is my final rotation
okay now you can see here if I rotated
one last time zip five we would did five
is he back here and the reason why is
because x i4 x is the same as
multiplying by negative 1/2 times which
is the same as multiplying by one and it
lands you back where you started
okay what's something you can do four
times and you end up back where you
begin and the answer is you rotate pilot
two radians and you get back there so
I'll just okay so therefore my
conclusion is multiplication
in the complex world multiplication is
rotation and now can you see why I was
insisting that negation really is
actually a kind of rotation
what is the negation negation is the
multiplication by a number right what is
my multiplying by negative one yeah I'm
multiplying by i where it takes me Payan
to radians right multiply by negative
one which was what I said negation is
right that's just multiplying by I twice
which is why you should PI on sir and
pilots who again gets you to PI see
what's going on so in fact that's why
indication is not really reflection even
though that's what it ends up looking
like okay negation is just a particular
example of multiplication it's
multiplication by negative one which is
gonna spin you around all the way table
to side okay